MANFRED ZABARAUSKAS: Hello
and welcome to Less Code, More
Services, Better Android Apps.
Thanks so much for coming.
I know we have a lot of great
sessions to choose from.
So we're both honored that
you are coming to ours.
My name's Manfred.
I'm a product manager
working at the intersection
of Android Studio
and Google Cloud.
JATIN LODHIA: And I'm Jatin.
I'm an Android engineer working
on sync and authentication.
And one of my
really good passions
is basically having
seamless transition
of users across
multiple devices.
MANFRED ZABARAUSKAS:
And that is actually
particularly important in
today's multi-device world.
So it doesn't matter if
you're writing an Android
game or a simple
task management app,
your users are
expecting their data
to be persistent
across multiple devices
and to be accessed
from anywhere.
In this session we're
going to show you
how to build mobile
apps which use
both new and existing Google
technologies to simplify Cloud
Datastorage,
online/offline interaction,
and synchronization
across multiple devices.
Throughout the session, you'll
see how Android Studio tooling
makes these tasks
straightforward
and allows you to bring the full
power of Google Cloud Platform
to your apps.
So we hope that we're
going to come away equipped
with new tools and new skills
to make your Android apps better
than ever without
having to write
hundreds of lines of code.
So the fact is that most of
the interesting applications
nowadays are powered by Cloud.
According to EDC
research, around 83%
of mobile app
developers last year
were planning to execute
some code on the Cloud.
And as early as in 2012,
already 63% of app developers
were using some sort
of Cloud storage APIs.
Now the main reason for that is
because we're all developers.
And we want to make our
applications more engaging.
And this might involve
using some data that's
changing rapidly.
So think about
whether-- or in my case,
think about today's
basketball scores.
Or you might want to store
data that's just simply
too large to store
on the device.
So think about a sample of
every song in the world, right?
It's not going to
fit on the device.
And then we also want to
make the data synchronized
across all of the devices
that your users might have.
So might be a phone, a tablet.
And if I add a task into a task
management app on my phone,
I want the same task to
be available on the tablet
as well.
So when you get one of these
crazy and exciting ideas,
you want to focus
on the core idea.
You don't want to worry
about servers, load balancer
configurations, content
distribution networks, and so
on.
Now the good thing is that
a lot of this complexity
is handled for you by Google
Cloud Endpoints, which
allow you to build powerful
backend APIs in a very
simple way.
So you can use familiar tools
and skills like Android Studio
and Java to develop not
only your Android apps,
but the backends
for them as well.
And you can start
communicating with your app
really, really easily by calling
the client libraries which
are produced for your
backend from the Android app.
And then finally, as
your application grows,
you're backend is also
going to scale automatically
because under the hood it's
actually powered by Google App
Engine which comes with
its own auto-scaling and
high-availability guarantees.
So here's a typical architecture
of a Cloud Endpoints powered
app.
On the right hand side,
you have the backend,
which is running on
Google App Engine.
And then on the
left hand side, you
have the clients, which might
be JavaScript, Android, iOS.
And these clients are using
Cloud Endpoint clients
libraries to communicate
with the backend.
This might seem a
little bit complicated
from the first slide.
But in reality Cloud Endpoints
define a very simple workflow.
So you start by writing
the endpoint, which
is the actual code which you
want to run in the backend.
And essentially all
that it is, it's
a simple Java class with
a couple of annotations.
So here I have my endpoint
class, and towards the middle
of the snippet I
have a method, sayHi.
It takes a string name and it
returns the response Hi, name.
Very simple.
Now I annotate my endpoint
class with an API annotation.
So I give it the name, myAPI.
And then, similarly,
I give the annotation
to the method which I want
to run in the backend.
And I give it the name, sayHi.
So myAPI, sayHi.
Once that is done I
can literally just
deploy this Java class of
Google App Engine backend.
And by the way, I don't
have to worry about things
like spending up App Engine
instances and things like that.
Google Cloud Endpoints take
care of all of that for me.
I deploy that to
the backend and it
starts running on
Google's infrastructure.
And then finally,
once that is done,
you can start calling the
strongly-typed mobile optimized
clients libraries
from your mobile app
which are derived from these
annotation which you just
put in the code.
So here's the same example.
If you remember I give the API
name, myAPI, and method, sayHi.
And this is a screenshot
from Android Studio where
you can see a myAPI
object exposed
which has a sayHi method.
All of these libraries which
I can call from Android Client
were generated just from
those simple annotations.
So at this point I'm actually
going to hand it over
to Jatin, who's going to give
us a simple example of how
to add the backend like
that from Android Studio.
JATIN LODHIA: All
right, I already
have Android Studio open
with project in there.
And what I'm going to do
is add them back into this.
It is going to be simple,
a couple of steps.
And then after that,
I'm going to run this.
Run the server locally and
then hit it with a browser
and show you that you
can actually hit it,
and what it can do with
it during deeper fazes.
So let's go and click
here, new module.
Select endpoint module.
Say next.
Let's name our backend, backend.
Pretty original.
So what you can
see here is that it
created a folder named backend.
And it has the
exact same classes
which Manfred just mentioned.
So you can see my
endpoints here.
And it's basically the endpoint
which we are going to show you,
and it uses something called
my bean, which is a bean.
And this bean is
used for sending
data between the
client and the server.
So if we would quickly run
this-- If we click run,
it's going to start
off a server here.
If you look at the gradle
file-- OK, there you go.
And we're going to
hit local host 80.80.
The server is already up and on.
What you see here is
an index.html file
which was auto-generated
for my Endpoints.
And if we write in I/O
Session here, and see.
Hello.
The server is going to respond
with Hi, I/O session, which
is the response which server
was supposed to give us.
One of the awesome
parts over here
is if you look at
this, the little tab,
it's called Endpoints
API Explorer.
We click through it.
It's going to take you
to a dashboard which
is going to show you all of the
APIs present on your server.
You can see my API over here.
If you click through this
It'll list you all the methods
your API has.
In this case, it's sayHi.
If you click through that
you'll see a form there.
This form is used to create
a request right from your web
browser.
And let's say-- let's
enter Manfred's name here.
And execute.
So the server is going
to return Hi, Manfred.
But if you look
at the bottom half
of the screen you can see
the exact request which
was sent to the server
and the exact response
the server sent back.
And you can see how
it was structured,
which is really
important if you need
to debug something
in your server.
Let's see if we can actually
have a demo here which--
like an example.
MANFRED ZABARAUSKAS: Yeah.
I mean, by all means,
let's do an example.
We're going to
show you how to use
Cloud Endpoints
in your actual app
to make it a bit more engaging.
Some of you might have seen
this app at the keynote earlier
yesterday.
Essentially, it's a
very simple Android
app which lets me to record
my path, distance, speed,
elevation, as I run, jog, bike,
do anything else outdoors.
And in this screenshot you
can see one of my walks
earlier today around
the Google campus.
While the app is
pretty cool already,
me and Jatin had
a few good ideas
on how we could make
it a bit more engaging.
So here's one.
When I go for a jog
I often get bored
by always taking the same route.
Wouldn't it be cool if when I
clicked on the track button,
down right in the
corner, it would
show me an interesting location
within my jogging radius
so that I could get both
fit, and see something new.
Something like that, right.
So Jatin, how would one
go about putting together
an endponts backend which
does something like this?
JATIN LODHIA: Sure, I can
show it to you in a minute.
So I already have this
project open here,
and we already did some
changes to the My Endpoints API
to return us the correct
response we wanted.
So I will walk you through
the code which-- the changes
which we made.
So let's look at the
server side code first.
So if you remember we had
the class name, MyEndpoints.
We renamed it to
SuggestAPIEndpoint.
Now within this, we
change the name of the API
to Suggest instead of myAPI,
and we renamed the method name
to Destination.
Now this method takes in two
variables, two parameters,
the latitude and the longitude.
And what we're
going to do here is
take these two
latitudes and longitudes
and figure out this random
point nearby and return that.
And along with that,
we are going to slap
on a quick description
of what that point is.
And we pick that from one of
the three static description
we have.
If you notice, we also
change the bean here.
We just renamed it
to DestinationBean
and we added a few
more data to it.
So if you click
through it, the bean
contains the new latitude
and longitude along
with a description.
So once the server
sends back this bean,
the client will
receive the bean,
and the client's stub is
going to give this bean back
to your application.
Let's look at the changes we
made in the application code.
We added a new class called
endpoints AsyncTask, which
is an asynchronous AsyncTask
provided by Android.
And in the constructor
of this class
we created a stub for our API.
If you remember, we
named the API Suggest,
so the stub which was created
is also named Suggest.
And once we have the stub-- here
we call the method destination
on it, pass it the current
latitude and longitude
of the device, and
we call execute.
So the execute method returns
us the destination bean
returned from the server.
And this is what is returned
back from the class.
And the UI takes care
of looking at this bean
and displaying it on our device.
Lets quickly run
this on our device.
I'm going to click
play here, which
is going to compile
the code and ship it
to my device, which
is right here.
Let's switch over
to the projector.
So the app should soon
come up over here as soon
as the compilation is done
and it pushes the app.
There you go.
All right.
We are near Mission and 4th,
and Marconi Center here.
OK.
We're going to hit
the track button
and this is supposed to
go and hit our server.
The server is going
to respond back
with an interesting
destination nearby.
There you go.
If we zoom out.
There it is.
Oh, the world's
deepest rabbit hole.
MANFRED ZABARAUSKAS: Wow!
Cool.
All right, this is a
good time to clap, guys.
[APPLAUSE]
All right.
Thanks, Jatin.
So the keenest of
you can actually
try to deduce the
probability of what
are the chances to
get the same message.
And it was one out
of three because we
had three static descriptions.
All right, so let me move on.
Let me just quickly
summarize what
we've seen so far
in the session.
You've seen that Jatin
used Java plus Android
Studio to the write the
code both for the backend
and for his Android app.
And then you've seen
that Cloud Endpoints took
care of almost all
of the plumbing.
So object serialization,
deserialization, compression,
encryption using SSL, generating
client libraries, all of that
was taken care of
by Cloud Endpoints.
And that's great for
us as developers,
but it's actually really
good for our users as well.
So the fact that all the JSON
objects are automatically
compressed as they
go over the wire
means that our apps use minimal
amount of networking, which
in turn increases
the battery life.
And similarly, the fact that all
the data is encrypted using SSL
means that your
user's information
is secure, and so on.
So finally, the
fact that endpoints
backends are deployed
on Google App Engine
means that your apps stay
responsive and available
as your user base grows since
your app can actually now
take advantage of Google's
infrastructure and Google's
data centers across the world.
OK, so all of that's pretty
cool, but at this point,
let me switch gears a bit.
There are many cases
when you don't actually
need to run custom
code in the backend
to make your applications
more engaging.
In many cases, all you want
to do is to make sure that
your app does not suffer
from what I call "app-nesia."
And that's basically
a disease that
causes your app to
forget it's users.
So by a show of hands, how
many of you at some point
have reinstalled an
app and discovered
that it forgot something about
you, like user preferences
or might be the game save state?
Quite a few of you.
So last year, we announced Cloud
Save, a game save storage API
with the goal of never
having your users to have
repeat the same level in a game.
Now, this year, we're very
happy to announce a new API
for all Android app
developers called Google Cloud
Save for Android, which makes
it really easy to store user's
data in the cloud,
and to synchronize it
across all of the users devices.
This new API is
really useful when
you want to store
some structured data.
It might be some applications
specific preferences.
Like if I have a
stock portfolio app
and I want to add
the stock ticker,
and I want the same stock ticker
to be available for the users
across all of the devices,
you can use Cloud Save.
Furthermore, you
can actually use
it to store any generic
structured user data.
So tasks in a task management
app or planned journey
in the travel planning app.
And the really great
thing about this new API
is that it requires
zero backend programing.
So all you do is, you write
the client side code to store
and query data, and then
the backend for your app
is fully managed by Google.
And the other thing that
I'm really excited about
is we still have access to
all of your user's data.
So if you want to run
some statistical analysis
to get a better insight into how
your users are using the app,
or if you want to run some
big data tools like BigQuery
to aggregate the data and
expose it via some sort of web
dashboard, you have
full access to it.
And then finally,
this API is ideally
suited for the
mobile device world.
So as your user's data
is saved in the backend.
It's automatically
synchronized across all
of the user's devices.
And you don't have to
write a single line of code
to handle them.
So some of you in the
audience might actually
be worrying that there's going
to be a lot of coordinator
cases to handle the
offline scenario.
You don't have to worry
about that either.
Even if the connection is
lost as soon as the app is
downloaded, it's going
to work just fine.
And the data is going to be
automatically synchronized
immediately after your
app comes back online.
And you won't have to
write a single line of code
to do that either.
So anyway, I think
at this point I
might have sold it just enough.
I'm going to hand it
over back to Jatin, who's
going to give you more technical
details about Cloud Save.
JATIN LODHIA:
Thank you, Manfred.
So with increasing
popularity of Android,
users have been buying
more and more devices.
So nowadays users
have multiple devices.
For example, in this case, if
they have a phone and a tablet,
and there's an issue here.
With standalone apps
you end up either
having to figure out how to
sync the data across the two,
or you will have to deal
with having fragmented data
across two different devices,
which is a pretty sucky user
experience.
With Cloud Save we provide
you a solution to figure,
due to synchronize data
across multiple devices,
and at the same time have the
data be stored in the backend.
This allows you to
focus on your app
and trying to figure out
the logic of your app,
whereas we take care of
all the details regarding
synchronization and
sorting in the cloud.
The best part about this
is that all this data
is stored in your project.
It's your developer
console project
where the data gets stored.
Which means that you
have full access to this,
you have full
ownership of the data.
What does this mean for you?
Well, it means that you can
have queries run on this data.
Or you can have dashboards
running on this data.
You can expose this
data to the user.
And when your app becomes really
successful-- and just in case,
if you make a bug and
there's a data corruption.
Bear with me.
I know this doesn't happen, but
just in case, if it happens,
you can go back, have
a small App Engine
app which runs our MapReduce
and fix the data on the backend.
So it basically provides
you a wholesome,
[INAUDIBLE] data on your end.
Now in the next
few slides we are
going to show you what the API
looks like and how to use this.
But to do this, we're going to
take the help of our WalkShare
app as an example and step you
through different parts of it.
And we'll show you a
demo also at the end.
Now, before we go into
this, let me remind you
that WalkShare app stores
two types of things.
One is the trail on
which you walked.
And as a part of the trail,
there are multiple waypoints.
So there's a trail.
A group of waypoints
belong to a trail.
Now Cloud Save,
we have something
called an entity which forms
the unit of our stored data
structure.
And it also forms a
unit of sync for us.
So for those of you
who have already
used Datastore from Cloud,
this measures the data sources
entity.
For those of you who
haven't used that,
let me show you
what it looks like.
An entity has a key.
And this key is formed of two
parts-- a kind and a name.
Kind is something like a class.
And you can have
multiple entities
sitting in the same
class, like a group.
And the name is a unique
identifier within this class.
So once you have an entity,
you can set properties on it.
And these properties
can have different types
from a list of types we support.
For example, strings, binaries,
booleans, and many more.
We also support
lists, by the way.
You can have as many entities
as you want and store them.
And we encourage you to
have smaller entities.
Smaller entities make
better sync performance.
And at the same time,
you have less amount
of conflicts when you
try to save something.
We'll come back to conflicts
a little bit later.
Before that, I want to show
you a little bit other things
we provide via Cloud Save.
So we also have built-in
user authentication.
What does it mean?
All we have to do is let
the user select an account
that they want to
use, and then you
can pass that account to us.
We take care of authentication.
We take care of partitioning
your data based on the user.
And we make sure that one
user cannot access another
user's data.
And by the way, all this
data and the data structure
in the backend, is
already visible to you,
so you have full power over it.
Currently, we only
support Google accounts.
But in future, we do plan to
have more than Google accounts
as the authentication systems
or authentication providers.
Let's talk about where the
API exists and how to use it.
We provide Cloud Save as a
part of Google Play services.
And for those you
who have already
used Google Play services,
you already know what this is.
For those of you who
have not used it,
let me just give you a brief
explanation of what this is.
Google API Client
is a stub, or it's
a client-side stub which
is provided to you,
or is present as a
part of your app.
And it helps you talk to
services inside Google Play
services.
All you have to do is create
a Google API client using
its builder, add the
APIs you want to use.
So in this particular case,
it's CloudSaveManager.API.
Then add a scope,
add the account
which the user selected,
and add a few callbacks.
Now an interesting part
about Android Studio
is that Android
Studio sort of creates
this boilerplate code for you.
So all you've got to do
is right-click on the app,
select Google, Google
Play Services activity,
and enable Cloud Save.
So if you enable
Cloud Save it'll
already created an activity
called Google Play services
activity which has the Google
API client already in there
created for you with
the correct API.
It already has a few callbacks,
like generic callbacks,
and it's pretty easy
to start off with.
We work pretty hard to
keep the API simple.
And, believe me, it's pretty
hard to keep things simple.
The reason behind
keeping an API simple
is that we believe that
the simpler the API is,
the easier it is
for you to use it.
So as a part of
this API, we provide
you a few simple
methods, namely save,
delete, query and requestSync.
At this point, let me note
that requestSync is only
provided to you so that in
case your app needs to provide
something like refresh
button to your users,
then you can use this
method, wire the button.
Otherwise, you don't need
to think about sync at all.
We take care of syncing
everything in the backend--
or in the background.
And you don't need
to think about when
to sync, when not to sync,
or anything about it.
It's provided only if you want
to expose this to the user.
Let's drill down
into one of the APIs.
Let's say you want
to save some data.
All you have to do
is create the list
of entities you want to save,
then call CloudSaveManager.save
and provide it the API
client, and also provide it
the list of entities
you want to save.
And that's it.
It's going to return
you a pending result.
And this pending result
is like a future object
where you can either
set a callback,
so when the result arrives,
the callback will be called,
or you can just call the
blocking record of it,
and you can wait for
the result to come back.
Once you have stored
this data, the next thing
is you want to read it.
So for reading data, we provide
a very simple but effective
querying API.
As part of that API, we provide
you an object called query
where you can set filters.
Now let us see what kind
of filters there are.
You can set a list
of keys as filters.
So if you already know what
entities you want to fetch
and you already have
the keys for it,
you can just set the
keys in the filters
and it will return you entities
belonging to those keys.
There's another filter
which is, you can set kind.
You can say, give
me all the entities
which belong to this
particular kind.
In our case, it can be something
like, give me all entities
where the kind is waypoints.
And then you also have
filters based on properties.
So you can say, give
me all the entities
which have property with
name equals something,
and the value equals blah.
Let's take an example with
respect to WalkShare app.
You have a list of trails.
When you want to display the
trail, you click on the trail
and then you need
all the waypoints
belonging to that trail.
You need to query all the
waypoints at that point.
What we have done here is that
we created a query object.
We set the kind as waypoint.
And we set the property as trail
ID equals the ID of the trail.
And then we called
CloudSaveManager.query.
We pass in the API
client and we pass
in the query object
we just created.
This returns a pending result,
and as I explained earlier,
it's like a future object.
Once we have written, we read.
But how about conflicts?
All of you would already
know what conflicts
are, but let me give a quick
idea of what's happening here.
When you have multiple
devices both of them
read the same entity.
One tries to write, the server
says good, you are good to go.
The other tries to write,
and the server says hey,
there's a conflict.
Now how do we handle
conflicts when they arise?
It's simple.
We just let you handle it.
[LAUGHTER]
But in order to do that, we
do provide you a lot of help
and a lot of structure.
What we have here is something
called BaseEventService.
You just have to
implement this service.
And as a part of this
service we provide
you a method called onConflict.
This method receives
three parameters,
three different versions
of the same entity
which was under conflict.
The first is local, which is
the local version which you just
wrote.
Second is the base.
And the third is remote.
Remote is the version
which the server has.
Now the base entity is basically
the least common ancestor
of the two, local and remote.
Which means that
you basically can
do a three-way merge over here.
Once you resolve it, you
return back the resolved entity
and we take care of
storing the resolved entity
in the local database.
And as soon as
it's done, we also
sync it across all
the devices for you.
You don't have to think about
how to sync it, how store it,
and stuff.
Now we're trying to keep
it as simple as possible.
To do that, we shoved
all the boilerplate code
inside the BaseEventService.
And we also provide you
some tools for doing Diffs,
so that given two entities, you
can use the tool to get a Diff.
And after that, we also provide
you a simple three-way merge.
So using this, if the conflict
is not a complicated conflict,
it will resolve it for you.
If your app is more
complex and if it
needs to have more complex
solution for the conflict,
then you can do that, too.
Because you already have the
three different versions,
you can do your own
three-way merge.
And at the same time,
because the resolution
is happening at an
entity level, you
have a pretty good context
of what the entity means
or what the data is.
So with that context you can
actually do a much better
merge yourself, a
much smarter merge.
Now last but not the
least, sync optimizations.
Because the sync happens
in the background
we have the benefit
of batching things.
So we do try to do that.
We try to batch
things up so that we
have a better
performance on battery.
We also take care of push
notifications for you,
which means that whenever
there's a change in the server
we'll send a notification
to all the devices
and the devices will
sync to this new data.
We're also aware of Wi-Fi
versus cellular network, which
means that, depending
on which network
we are on we'll
either go full-blast
or we can throttle back.
At this point let's
see if we can actually
have a quick example.
MANFRED ZABARAUSKAS: Absolutely.
Quick stretch break.
I know you guys are like--
Your seats are not comfortable,
so if you want to
move the shoulders
or stretch back a bit,
take a little break.
We're going to do
an example of how
to use Cloud Save
to basically take
the data from the mobile
phone-- I finish the jog,
I have the track on my phone.
I want that same track to be
saved on my Cloud Save backend
so that when I come back
home, I pick up my tablet,
and I see the same track there.
So let's see, how
can we do this?
Here's a class in
Android Studio.
There it is.
Cold storage adaptor.
WalkShare app was
using this class
to save data on
the local storage.
So it has three methods,
save to storage,
read trails from storage,
read waypoint from storage.
What we've done is, we've blown
away the local storage code
and we've added Cloud
Save Manager calls.
We take the Google
API client, which
is generated by Android
Studio, and entities
that we want to
save, and we pass it
to
GoogleCloudSaveManager.savecall.
Similarly, to get
trails from storage
we form the query using
the stuff that Jatin just
described in the slides and we
call CloudSaveManager.query.
As simple as that.
Let me actually run this app on
the phone and see what happens.
I know this is a bit of,
like, electromagnetic storm
in the building so,
fingers crossed.
OK.
The bits are flying across
the USB cable from the laptop
to the phone, and there we go.
OK.
Just to show you
the history tab,
there's a single
track in the history
and this is actually
from the earlier today.
And if I start the tracking,
tracking first time.
Stop the tracking.
Switch back to the history tab.
Woo-hoo!
Two tracks.
To prove you guys
that this is not magic
and trickery, let me switch
to a Cloud Datastore.
Here's the list of all the
entities in the datastore.
Right now there's nothing,
so I refresh the query.
Woo-hoo!
Two tracks.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you very much.
And one final clap
opportunity is,
Jatin, if you
refresh your tablet,
let's see if we can get the
same tracks on your tablet.
JATIN LODHIA: We kept
the tablet clean.
We didn't refresh anything.
Now we're going top refresh it.
It's empty right now.
Refresh.
Go back to the thing.
Come back to the history.
Nice.
There it is.
[APPLAUSE]
MANFRED ZABARAUSKAS:
Thanks so much, guys.
You're very generous.
Let me just, super
quickly, summarize
what we've seen so far.
You've seen that all of the
code that I touched in Android
Studio was client-side code,
so no backend programming
was involved.
We still had access to the
data using Cloud Datastore.
And as Jatin described
earlier, Cloud Save
comes with really good online
and offline scenario support,
so things like conflict
resolution, background
synchronization,
knowledge whether you're
on cellular connection
or Wi-Fi, and so on.
Today we're excited to open
Cloud Save via early access
program to a limited
set of initial users.
If you want to help us to
make Cloud Save for Android
even better please use
the link above to sign up.
We're very much interested
in hearing your feedback
and suggestions on how we
could improve Cloud Save even
further before we release
it to a wider audience.
And if you want to get more
information about Cloud
Endpoints, which we've shown in
the first half of the session,
we've put together an
end-to-end backend code
lab which you can just
take it at your own pace
when you go back home.
And if you want to take your
idea even beyond the feature
that Cloud Endpoints provide,
go to g.co/cloudstarterpack
and enter promo code GoogleIO
to get $500 credit for Google
Cloud Platform.
All right, so
that's all we have.
I thank you very
much, and we're going
to open the floor for questions.
AUDIENCE: Can you bring
the previous slide back?
MANFRED ZABARAUSKAS: Absolutely.
The one with the $500 or?
Oh yeah.
AUDIENCE: Can you go
to the next one now?
MANFRED ZABARAUSKAS: We still
will have a few phones up so,
going four going three--
JATIN LODHIA: While
you take that picture
I'll take a picture for you.
[LAUGHTER]
MANFRED ZABARAUSKAS: Going two.
Going one.
Still a few folks, sorry.
Good for eye is not
amazing for cell phones.
For those of you who are still
trying to get the picture,
these lines will be posted
when the trail is published
and recorded so you'll have
the opportunity there as well.
All right, and the $500 slide.
There it is.
OK, yes, a question.
AUDIENCE: Two questions.
One is, how do you
support sharing data
across multiple users?
And then two is, what about
sharing on non-Android devices?
JATIN LODHIA: Basically, the
sharing across multiple users
is not there yet.
It will probably be a
feature in the future,
but it's not present right now.
MANFRED ZABARAUSKAS:
Having said that,
the data is stored in
the Cloud Datastore,
so if you're using-- the
first half of the session,
if you're using Cloud
Endpoints, then you
can basically expose
an endpoint which
uses basically
Datastore operations.
Wire App Engine
backend, and then you
can just expose data that way.
And then, second
question was support
for non-Android devices.
Good news is that
it's on our radar.
Bad news is that I cannot give
you the exact date at this
point.
AUDIENCE: I was
wondering, is there
any listeners for
when the sync happens?
JATIN LODHIA: Is
there any listeners?
Yes.
So there is basically something,
an API called onRemoteChange,
put in the base intent
service, BaseEventService,
and it lets you know as
soon as an entity changes.
And it gives you a list
of entities that changed.
MANFRED ZABARAUSKAS: Sorry,
I was unfair to that side.
two questions from
that side now.
AUDIENCE: The form
on the sign-up page
is not publicly shared.
MANFRED ZABARAUSKAS:
Oh, that's a bummer.
OK.
Let me--
AUDIENCE: Is there a
form we can fill out
to get it shared to us?
MANFRED ZABARAUSKAS: Yes.
Basically, as soon as
I leave the podium,
I'll take care of that.
Thank you very much.
One more question.
AUDIENCE: Is there a
way to purge local data
and then later restore it so
you don't fill up locally?
JATIN LODHIA: Is there a
way to purge local data.
We do cache everything
locally so, not yet.
Because we want your app to
be able to run online as well
as offline, so as soon as a user
doesn't have data connection,
they should be able
to use the app still.
So that in the goal
of this service.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
MANFRED ZABARAUSKAS: That side.
AUDIENCE: So I know how
to use that data store,
and I know it has some quirks,
especially around indexing.
If you want to query on two
properties at the same time,
you have to generate
a double index.
How do you guys handle that?
Automatically?
JATIN LODHIA: On the back end?
Is your question
about the Android or?
You running Android.
AUDIENCE: With Cloud Save, if
I'm querying on two properties,
how are you going
to handle that?
JATIN LODHIA: We don't
have the same constraints
as App Engine does.
We don't have to go through
a huge amount of data.
It's just one users
data for one app,
so we can easily, smartly do
filtering inside the data.
It's not a huge amount of
data we have to go through,
so we can do it.
AUDIENCE: So you
filter in memory?
JATIN LODHIA: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
AUDIENCE: What's the storage
mechanism on the client side?
Is it file based
or SQLite based?
JATIN LODHIA: It's SQLite based.
AUDIENCE: And you guys handle
completely the CRUD on that?
JATIN LODHIA: Yes.
I'm sorry, we handle
completely what, on that?
AUDIENCE: The CRUD.
Create, read, update, delete.
JATIN LODHIA: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Do we, for
Android Cloud Store,
does that start out free and
you just pay for App Engine
when you start adding more Logic
and other access to the cloud,
or is that always kind
of a subscription thing?
MANFRED ZABARAUSKAS:
You mean on Cloud Save?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, sorry.
Cloud Save.
MANFRED ZABARAUSKAS:
So basically,
when you join the
Early Access program,
we're going to give you a
free quota for every user,
of your every app.
Having said that, one of the
reasons why we're trying it out
first as an early access
program is to figure out
what that quota limit should
be when we roll it out
to a wider audience.
AUDIENCE: So it'll always be
kind of a free small data quota
and then you just pay
for heavy-use apps?
MANFRED ZABARAUSKAS:
So at this moment,
the details are not
finalized in terms
of how it's going to be handled.
At the moment for early
access program, yes.
But, you know,
we're trying to make
sure what makes most sense and
kind of what's best for you
guys.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: And then,
two questions.
Is the Google Cloud storage
built on top of the endpoints?
And are the endpoints-- is there
like a JavaScript interface?
When you compile
that API method,
is it a rest interface or
is there any library that?
MANFRED ZABARAUSKAS:
Yes and yes, basically.
Endpoints have JavaScript client
libraries which get generated
and kind of
strongly-- they learn
those annotations
which you provide.
So from those
annotations, you can
generate iOS client libraries,
Android client libraries,
that's basically what we've
seen in the demo, and then
JavaScript.
I don't know if you
remember, it was
like of the relatively fine
point, when the web UI was
generated automatically, enter
the name, press hello button,
and then there was Hi,
IO session at the top.
That was basically calling the
JavaScript client libraries,
which were generated for
that particular back-up.
And then regarding the
second question, yes.
It automatically
generates a RESTful API
from those annotations.
And so if you
basically want to call
that using some other things you
have to parcel adjacent objects
and things like that, but you
still have full access to them.
JATIN LODHIA: To answer your
first question, the Cloud save.
It uses a special API
we created for doing
a more optimized sync.
AUDIENCE: OK, so
it wouldn't have--
You couldn't use
these other access
methods to work with Cloud Save?
JATIN LODHIA: We could have.
We just have other
infrastructure inside so--
AUDIENCE: For larger assets
like JPEGs and stuff,
if I have lots of
those, I should
use this for the metadata
and something else for those?
MANFRED ZABARAUSKAS: Correct.
And a good place
to do that would
be using Google Cloud Storage,
so the big object storage.
And then expose an endpoint.
Using kind of the first
half of this session,
expose the endpoint which
just transmits the JPEG.
AUDIENCE: So it looks you guys
support some spatial queries,
like proximity.
But can you give more details?
Like what other kinds?
You know, like
bounds or polygons?
MANFRED ZABARAUSKAS: Yeah, so
if I understand the question
correctly, it relates
to, how did we
put the marker close
to the location?
AUDIENCE: No.
For example, I can
store points, right?
Lat/Longs.
MANFRED ZABARAUSKAS: Correct.
AUDIENCE: And I could say hey,
can you grab me the nearest,
like within 10 mile
radius, all of the points.
MANFRED ZABARAUSKAS: Yeah.
So what we had done there is
actually a custom backend code
so you can literally
do whatever you want.
For this actual demo, we
just generated the point
to kind of randomly
within the radius.
Don't tell that to anyone.
I'm kidding.
You'll see in the code, if
you watch the recording,
it was just generated kind of
randomly within a mile radius
around the current location.
AUDIENCE: So you cannot
store geometry points
on the database?
JATIN LODHIA: You can.
MANFRED ZABARAUSKAS:
You totally can.
It's just we didn't use
it for this session.
AUDIENCE: All right, Thanks.
MANFRED ZABARAUSKAS:
One last question.
AUDIENCE: So for the
L developer preview
they introduced what
seemed like a new lifecycle
to optimize battery use.
Is this plugged into some of
the things from project Volta?
Or you guys usually sync
adapters, kind of like,
in the old way?
JATIN LODHIA: Right now
we use sync adapters.
And we do plan to use-- We
do actually use the new,
it's called Task Scheduler,
GCM Task Scheduler--
network [INAUDIBLE] I think.
We do use that
for certain things
which need us to delay
a sync in the future.
AUDIENCE: Will this shift
over to the Volta approach
going forward?
JATIN LODHIA: Depends.
When we need to
write, we would like
to write as soon as
the network is up.
So we would use the
Volta approach for it.
But when we need to sync, based
on the remote notifications,
we already have the
network up because we just
received the notification.
We just need to do a
sync at that point.
So then it will
use a sync monitor.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MANFRED ZABARAUSKAS: All right.
Cool.
Thanks, guys.
[APPLAUSE]